The following episode of How We Made Your Mother was recorded live on Instagram on January 21st, 2026.
《How We Made Your Mother》的下一集于 2026 年 1 月 21 日在 Instagram 上现场录制。
It was our first Instagram live and you'll hear Josh Craig start out by introducing the podcast for first-time listeners.
这是我们的第一次 Instagram 直播，您会听到 Josh Craig 首先为初次听众介绍播客。
And then they took questions from around the world that were coming into us right then and they're live in the moment.
然后他们回答了来自世界各地的问题，这些问题当时就在我们面前，他们就在当下。
Here we go.
开始了。
All right we're doing this.
好吧，我们正在做这个。
Hi everyone.
大家好。
Hi.
你好。
Hey.
嘿。
Hi people.
大家好。
I'm having to trust that this is is really happening, Alec.
我必须相信这真的发生了，亚历克。
Alec is running tech tonight, so Craig and I are just trusting that you're all seeing us.
亚历克今晚负责技术工作，所以克雷格和我相信你们都会看到我们。
It's very disconcerting that we're not seeing people writing in things, because it feels like nothing's happening, but I think things are happening.
令人非常不安的是，我们没有看到人们在写东西，因为感觉就像什么都没有发生，但我认为事情正在发生。
It helps me.
它对我有帮助。
Well, let's just do some introductions.
好吧，我们就做一些介绍吧。
My name is Josh Radner.
我叫乔什·拉德纳。
I was on a TV show called How I Met Your Mother.
我参加了一个名为《老爸老妈浪漫史》的电视节目。
It ran for nine years on CBS.
它在哥伦比亚广播公司播出了九年。
played a character named Ted Mosby from 2005 to 2014.
2005年至2014年期间，他扮演了一个名叫特德·莫斯比（Ted Mosby）的角色。
That knows of the years.
就知道这些年了。
My friend Craig Thomas, who's with me here, either he's here, he co-created this show with his pal Carter Bays.
我的朋友克雷格·托马斯（Craig Thomas）和我在一起，他也在这里，他和他的朋友卡特·贝斯（Carter Bays）共同创作了这个节目。
And we, Craig and I, love each other, have maintained a very strong and deep friendship over the years.
我和克雷格彼此相爱，多年来一直保持着非常牢固和深厚的友谊。
I got married a couple years ago.
几年前我结婚了。
My wife, Jordana, had never seen how I met your mother, which actually helped a lot in our courtship.
我的妻子乔丹娜从未见过我是如何认识你母亲的，这实际上对我们的求爱有很大帮助。
But she was not in love with Ted.
但她并不爱特德。
No, she met me.
不，她遇见了我。
And she said, I've never seen this show that a lot of strangers on the street approach you about.
她说，我从来没有看过这样的节目，街上有很多陌生人接近你。
And I would love to fill in the gaps and know about this part of your life.
我很乐意填补空白并了解您生活的这一部分。
So I reached out to Craig and I said, I'm gonna rewatch how I met your mother after not having seen it for many years with my wife.
所以我联系了克雷格，我说，我要重新看一下我是如何遇见你母亲的，因为我和我的妻子已经很多年没有见过它了。
And do you wanna, maybe we should do something formal and start a podcast and re-watch the show, 19 years after it started.
你想吗，也许我们应该做一些正式的事情，开始播客，并在节目开始 19 年后重新观看。
So we got our buddy Alec Lev, who was woven into the How I Met Your Mother family, and also went to college with Carter and Craig.
所以我们找到了我们的好友亚历克·列夫（Alec Lev），他融入了《老爸老妈的浪漫史》家庭，并且还与卡特和克雷格一起上大学。
And so we've been re-watching the show.
所以我们一直在重新观看这个节目。
The podcast is called How We Made Your Mother.
该播客名为“我们如何创造了你的母亲”。
You can listen wherever you stream your podcasts, and we just finished the second season.
您可以在任何播放播客的地方收听，我们刚刚完成了第二季。
So we just finished the one, two punch something borrowed, something blue with Marshall and Lily's wedding.
所以我们刚刚完成了马歇尔和莉莉婚礼上借来的、蓝色的一、二拳。
So there's now what, like 50 episodes you can listen to, Alex, something like that?
那么现在你可以听 50 集之类的东西吗？
Yeah, from season one, we did all 22 episodes plus a whole bunch of bonuses.
是的，从第一季开始，我们就制作了全部 22 集，外加一大堆奖金。
I mean, probably 15 or 16 bonus episodes, you can go back and listen to those.
我的意思是，大概有 15 或 16 集奖励，你可以回去听一下。
We had some bonus interviews with folks that weren't tied directly to an episode, but we had great guests on that.
我们对一些与剧集没有直接关系的人进行了一些额外的采访，但我们有很棒的嘉宾。
And then, yeah, now we've released only, I think, 12 from this season.
然后，是的，现在我们只发布了本季的 12 个。
We have just finished recording, all 22.
我们刚刚完成录制，总共 22 个。
So they'll finish up in March, releasing the season two?
那么他们会在三月份结束并发布第二季吗？
Yeah.
是的。
So we're thrilled for people who have been rewatching the show with us.
因此，我们为那些和我们一起重温这部剧的人们感到兴奋。
I was listening to an episode today, Craig, and I was thinking, if you wanted to get a master's degree or a PhD in how I met your mother, it's kind of an advanced college course in how I met your mother, right?
克雷格，我今天在听一集，我在想，如果你想获得关于我如何遇见你母亲的硕士学位或博士学位，这是关于我如何遇见你母亲的高级大学课程，对吧？
It is.
这是。
Yeah, it totally is.
是的，完全是这样。
Like we go very deep into the theme.
就像我们非常深入地探讨主题一样。
I mean, there's tons of like backstage anecdotes and funny things we remember, but we're also really interrogating what are the themes of how I met your mother.
我的意思是，我们记得有很多后台轶事和有趣的事情，但我们也在真正询问我如何遇见你母亲的主题是什么。
And the central mystery that we were super curious about is why there were a bunch of other shows very popular, even more popular than we were at the time, that people don't talk about anymore.
我们非常好奇的核心谜团是，为什么有很多其他节目非常受欢迎，甚至比我们当时更受欢迎，但人们不再谈论它们。
Yeah.
是的。
For some reason this show has such a long tail, It's stuck around, people keep discovering it.
由于某种原因，这个节目有这么长的尾巴，它被困住了，人们不断发现它。
It's a huge ratings hit on Disney Plus right now.
目前该片在迪士尼+上的收视率很高。
We hear from people all the time who learned how to speak English from watching how I met your mother.
我们一直听到人们通过观看我如何认识你母亲而学会了如何说英语。
Yeah, I should say Hulu in America, Disney Plus internationally, I should say that.
是的，我应该在美国说Hulu，在国际上说Disney Plus，我应该这么说。
Hulu very much wants us to message that Hulu in America is your now, your one-stop shopping, but Disney Plus and those are related companies.
Hulu 非常希望我们传达这样的信息：Hulu 在美国是您的现在、您的一站式购物，但 Disney+ 和那些是相关公司。
But yeah, it is, our feeling is the show has gotten more popular than ever.
但是，是的，我们的感觉是这个节目比以往任何时候都更受欢迎。
perhaps, and there's this whole new burgeoning crop of young humans discovering it that is just really exciting and cool.
也许吧，而且有一群新兴的年轻人发现了它，这真是令人兴奋和酷。
It's a wave, it's like a wave.
这是一个波浪，就像一个波浪。
So part of it is how we make our mother itself is a mystery.
所以部分原因是我们如何创造我们的母亲本身就是一个谜。
It's a mystery of how we met them.
我们如何认识他们是个谜。
But also, a lot of the episodes are mysteries in and of themselves, like Ted Mosby architect, or something weird brunch, something weird is happening, and then you backtrack and you figure out what's going on.
而且，很多剧集本身都是谜团，比如泰德·莫斯比建筑师，或者一些奇怪的早午餐，一些奇怪的事情正在发生，然后你回溯并弄清楚发生了什么。
And in some ways, because we're approaching or almost the age of narrator, older Ted.
在某些方面，因为我们正在接近或接近叙述者年长的特德的年龄。
So we're very close.
所以我们非常接近。
So we're very looking back on this time in our lives that was incredibly pivotal and powerful.
因此，我们非常回顾生命中的这段非常关键和强大的时期。
We were looking back as the artists who made this thing, but there's this kind of meta thing going on that we're around the age of older Ted telling his kids this story.
我们回顾了创造这个东西的艺术家，但有一种元的事情正在发生，我们大约是年长的特德告诉他的孩子们这个故事的年龄。
And yeah, it's crazy.
是的，这太疯狂了。
We are, it is a good show for a rewatch podcast because in doing the podcast, we're kind of doing what Future Ted did.
我们是的，对于重温播客来说，这是一个很好的节目，因为在制作播客时，我们正在做未来特德所做的事情。
just looking back on his life, making sense of it.
只是回顾他的一生，理解其中的意义。
And we want everybody to join us.
我们希望每个人都加入我们。
So, tell a friend, I went to the How I Met Your Mother bar in New York City to the bar, Carter and I used to drink at after we worked all week at Letterman, which is around the corner now.
所以，我告诉朋友，我去了纽约市的“老爸老妈浪漫史”酒吧，我和卡特在莱特曼工作了一个星期后经常去这家酒吧喝酒，莱特曼现在就在拐角处。
That's the whole better field used to go to the mall on soap dish to get recognized.
这是过去人们为了得到认可而拿着肥皂盒去商场的更好的领域。
When he's feeling a little low, he just wanders in the big ease.
当他心情有些低落的时候，他就在大轻松中徘徊。
In those rare moments when I'm feeling a little low, so I'm there six days a week.
当我情绪低落的时候，我会每周呆六天。
When I'm feeling a little needy, I was doing a book related event for my debut novel, I'll shame the book later.
当我感到有点需要时，我正在为我的处女作小说做一个与书籍相关的活动，稍后我会让这本书感到羞耻。
Fantastic book.
很棒的书。
Thank you, Josh.
谢谢你，乔什。
Josh does one of the voices in the audiobook.
乔什为有声读物中的其中一个声音配音。
It's fantastic.
太棒了。
And I went in there after this little book event and met some people in there who were great and they were young, they were like in their 20s and they were wonderful, they loved how much mother and they had no idea there was a podcast that we were doing looking back at how much mother and I was like, Josh and I are almost the age of future Ted.
在这次小型图书活动之后，我去了那里，在那里遇到了一些很棒的人，他们很年轻，他们就像 20 多岁，他们很棒，他们多么爱母亲，他们不知道我们正在做一个播客，回顾母亲和我的经历，乔什和我几乎是未来特德的年龄。
We're in the podcast, we're kind of doing what the show is.
我们在播客中，我们正在做节目的内容。
And they were like, cool, we're gonna seek that out, but our message is spread the word because I feel like those guys that had, one of them was from Spain, one of them was visiting from Florida.
他们说，很酷，我们会找出答案，但我们的信息已经传播开来，因为我觉得那些人，其中一个来自西班牙，其中一个来自佛罗里达州。
They were great people, and they came to the how much mother bar specifically.
他们都是很棒的人，特意来到了多少妈妈酒吧。
It was like very high on their New York itinerary on their trips.
这在他们的纽约行程中是非常重要的。
And I was like, you guys should know about this podcast.
我当时想，你们应该知道这个播客。
What are we doing wrong?
我们做错了什么？
that you don't know where this vlog is.
你不知道这个视频博客在哪里。
So please help us, friend.
所以请帮助我们，朋友。
What if it was just Florida and Spain?
如果只是佛罗里达和西班牙怎么办？
Just there was a media blackout in this podcast?
只是这个播客中出现了媒体封锁？
There's a blackout.
停电了。
No, we've been delighted so many people have found the show, but also there's so many other fans that I think would love to go on this journey with us.
不，我们很高兴有这么多人发现了这个节目，而且我认为还有很多其他粉丝愿意与我们一起踏上这段旅程。
So the great thing is all the episodes are banked, they're there, just start wherever you want.
所以最棒的是所有的剧集都被存储起来，它们就在那里，只要你想从任何地方开始就可以了。
I mean, just you can catch up really quick.
我的意思是，只要你能很快赶上。
They go down smooth, we're working with the office ladies this season, Angela, and Jenna, and everyone at Odyssey, and we're having a great time with them.
他们进展顺利，这一季我们正在与办公室女士、安吉拉和珍娜以及奥德赛的每个人一起工作，我们和她们一起度过了愉快的时光。
So yeah, I mean, what else, Alec?
是的，我的意思是，还有什么，亚历克？
Anything else?
还要别的吗？
Oh, so much else, let's definitely tell people they can go to how wemajormother.com.
哦，还有这么多，让我们明确告诉人们他们可以如何访问 wemajormother.com。
I'll tell them some things they could do there.
我会告诉他们一些他们可以在那里做的事情。
You could tell them some other things.
你可以告诉他们一些其他的事情。
Simplest form is, because a lot of people actually asking in the chat where they could find the podcast.
最简单的形式是，因为很多人实际上在聊天中询问在哪里可以找到播客。
So if you go to howweemajormother.com, there's links there to Apple podcasts and Spotify, but basically everywhere that you listen to podcasts, roughly speaking, you could find our podcast.
因此，如果您访问 howweemajormother.com，那里有 Apple 播客和 Spotify 的链接，但基本上在您收听播客的任何地方，粗略地说，您都可以找到我们的播客。
I do want to just say that our social media producer Emily is clocking where some folks are coming in from and we've got Argentina and China and in Colombia, and France, and Brazil, and Canada.
我确实想说，我们的社交媒体制作人艾米丽正在记录一些人来自哪里，我们有阿根廷、中国、哥伦比亚、法国、巴西和加拿大。
That's not at all, hello, hello, welcome.
完全不是这样的，你好，你好，欢迎光临。
That's just for starters right now.
现在这只是初学者。
And then, Josh, you wanna talk a little bit about what else people can do from the website?
然后，乔什，您想谈谈人们还可以通过该网站做些什么吗？
Cause that's not- Yeah, I mean, one of our favorite things on the podcast, we open with a voice note from a fan.
因为那不是 - 是的，我的意思是，我们在播客上最喜欢的事情之一，我们以粉丝的语音留言开始。
And all we're really asking people is, what does how I make your mother mean to you?
我们真正想问的是，我如何让你的母亲对你意味着什么？
How has it changed your life?
它如何改变了你的生活？
Moved you, when did you discover it?
感动了你，你什么时候发现的？
How it's accompanied you all these years?
这些年它是怎么陪伴你的？
what you've learned from it and so we start the show with a voice note and we end the show with a written letter.
你从中学到了什么，所以我们以语音笔记开始节目，以书面信件结束节目。
So you can reach out to us and maybe your letter or your voice note will end up on the air and we'll get to read it and relate with you on some level.
因此，您可以联系我们，也许您的信件或语音留言最终会播出，我们将阅读它并在某种程度上与您联系。
So all you got to do is go to how we made your mother.com and go to contact and then it should be pretty self-explanatory from there, right Alec?
因此，您所要做的就是转到我们如何创建您的 mother.com 并进行联系，然后从那里开始就应该非常不言自明了，对吧亚历克？
Absolutely, you can write you to the first night.
绝对可以，你可以写信给你第一个晚上。
So we've got questions coming in and for everyone here online.
因此，我们向在线的每个人提出了问题。
I'd love that you're all telling us where you're from.
我希望你们都能告诉我们你们来自哪里。
We've added some more here, Germany, Nicaragua, Australia, Kansas.
我们在这里添加了更多的国家：德国、尼加拉瓜、澳大利亚、堪萨斯州。
So cool, the Philippines, Texas.
太酷了，菲律宾，德克萨斯州。
But also, please ask some questions.
但也请问一些问题。
We're here, these folks can, you've got Craig, you've got Josh.
我们在这里，这些人可以，你有克雷格，你有乔希。
And our first question here, I'm gonna ask from Madaroski, who asks Josh, in all caps, is that the blue French horn?
我们的第一个问题是，我要问 Madaroski，他问 Josh，全部大写，那是蓝色圆号吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Oh, yes.
哦是的。
That's the actual blue French horn, which, for a long time, I was nervous about revealing the sight of it because I was worried about crazed, how I met my other friends breaking into my apartment and stealing it.
那是真正的蓝色法国号，很长一段时间，我都不敢公开它的景象，因为我担心我会疯狂地遇到其他朋友闯入我的公寓并偷走它。
But it's the one, you know, we were all given kind of the, we were told at the end, what's the one thing you want from the set?
但这是一个，你知道，我们都被赋予了一种，我们在最后被告知，你想从片场得到什么？
and I picked the blue French horn.
我选择了蓝色圆号。
And what did you take, Craig?
克雷格，你拿了什么？
I took Carl the bartender.
我带了调酒师卡尔。
He just makes me drinks now.
他现在只是给我喝酒。
When you're not at McGee's.
当你不在麦吉家的时候。
Yeah, the few days a week I'm not at McGee's rather get recognized.
是的，每周有几天我不在麦吉家，宁愿被认出来。
Carl is here in my home.
卡尔在我家。
No, I took a few things.
不，我拿了一些东西。
I got, so I got one of the two booths, the iconic two red booths at the table.
我得到了，所以我得到了两个摊位之一，桌子上标志性的两个红色摊位。
Neil took one.
尼尔拿了一张。
I took the other.
我拿了另一个。
I think Neil took the table top too, and Neil got more of that said than I did, but I got one of the red booze.
我想尼尔也拿走了桌面，尼尔说的比我多，但我得到了一杯红色酒。
And you know, the other thing I got is actually, I don't know if I said the name when I said I was at the How I Rich a Mother Bar today.
你知道，我得到的另一件事实际上是，我不知道当我说我今天在“如何让母亲致富”酒吧时我是否说了这个名字。
McGee's is the bar on 55th between Broadway and 8th.
McGee's 酒吧位于 55 号百老汇街和 8 号街之间。
It's fantastic.
太棒了。
We're so happy.
我们很高兴。
It's still alive and well and thriving.
它仍然生机勃勃、生机勃勃。
Due to you, due to all the How I Rich a Mother fans that come there that visit from everywhere.
感谢你们，感谢所有从各地来到这里的《我如何致富母亲》粉丝。
And they have on McGee's, like when Carter and I went our 20s, like walking around the block from writing for Letterman, and we would go in there.
他们在麦吉店里也有，就像卡特和我二十多岁的时候一样，就像为莱特曼写作后绕着街区走，我们会去那里。
And there are these beautiful, in addition to red booths, and we said, that's gonna be the look of the bar on how much mother, there were also these huge murals on the wall.
还有这些漂亮的，除了红色的摊位，我们说，这就是酒吧的样子，墙上还有这些巨大的壁画。
It is beautifully painted, sort of like WPA era murals.
它画得很漂亮，有点像 WPA 时代的壁画。
And we said, we want that too.
我们说，我们也想要那样。
And Steve Olson, our set designer in a cosmic twist, also lived one block away from McGee's and just around the same time Carter and I were writing for Letterman, like we were all right there.
史蒂夫·奥尔森（Steve Olson），我们宇宙扭曲的布景设计师，也住在离麦吉家一个街区远的地方，大约在同一时间卡特和我正在为莱特曼写作，就像我们都在那里一样。
And he was like, I know that bar, that was my local bar for a bunch of years.
他说，我知道那个酒吧，多年来那是我当地的酒吧。
I know exactly the look you're talking about.
我很清楚你所说的样子。
And so he created long story short, two great murals that were in the deep background of McLarens on how much a mother, and so I have those.
所以他创作了长话短说，两幅伟大的壁画，位于迈凯轮的深处，讲述了母亲的价值，所以我有这些。
I have one, one of them is about 15 feet long.
我有一个，其中一个长约 15 英尺。
It's gigantic.
这是巨大的。
It was the one that was all the way on the kind of like, when you're looking at it the leftmost wall and then sort of curving around the right wall and the deep left background is it was a matching smaller mural.
这是一个一直都是这样的，当你看它最左边的墙，然后在右边的墙周围弯曲时，最左边的背景是一幅匹配的较小的壁画。
Did I tell you?
我有告诉过你吗？
And I have both of those.
我两者都有。
I went to a Comic-Con months ago in Ecuador.
几个月前我参加了厄瓜多尔的动漫展。
Remember when I went there?
还记得我去那儿的时候吗？
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
And I said you pictures, they had recreated, they had built an entire McLaren set.
我说你的照片，他们重新制作了，他们建造了整个迈凯伦布景。
And it looked really good.
看起来真的很棒。
It was good.
很好。
Like legit set design when I'm into doing that, and that's so cool.
当我喜欢这样做时，就像合法的布景设计一样，这太酷了。
The other thing I have, Josh, I'm nervous to tell you I have, I don't know if I've ever told you I have this, lest you come steal it, like you're afraid of a blue French one being stolen.
我有另一件东西，乔什，我很紧张地告诉你我有，我不知道我是否曾经告诉过你我有这个，以免你来偷它，就像你害怕蓝色法国的被偷一样。
In my room, in my bedroom, under that second smaller mural, I have Ted's architect table.
在我的房间里，在我的卧室里，在第二幅较小的壁画下面，有特德的建筑师桌。
If you want it, I'll give it to you.
如果你想要，我就给你。
No, I don't care.
不，我不在乎。
I don't care.
我不在乎。
But wait, did Carter take the jukebox?
但是等等，卡特拿走了点唱机吗？
Yeah, I don't think he took the jukebox.
是的，我不认为他拿走了点唱机。
Do you know what Kobe and Ellie and Jason took?
你知道科比、艾莉和杰森拿走了什么吗？
I don't, I don't.
我不，我不。
Carter, I know took like the piano that was in there.
卡特，我知道喜欢那里的钢琴。
I think he still has that.
我认为他仍然有这一点。
The piano that was in the apartment.
公寓里的钢琴。
Yeah, I'm sitting here also with a lamp.
是的，我也拿着灯坐在这里。
Can I possibly hold this up on camera?
我可以在镜头前举起这个吗？
This is a lamp from the bar.
这是酒吧里的一盏灯。
Oh yeah.
哦，是的。
Honestly, just on my desk in my room.
老实说，就在我房间的桌子上。
You know, we were watching, Jordiana and my wife and I, we were watching an episode the other night and it was a bar scene, just like an normal average, how I made your mother bar scene.
你知道，我们在看，乔丹娜和我的妻子，那天晚上我们在看一集，那是一个酒吧场景，就像正常的平均水平一样，我是如何制作你母亲的酒吧场景的。
And I was just like, I spent so much time in that bar.
我当时就想，我在那个酒吧里度过了很多时间。
I used to drink.
我以前喝过。
Drinking fake beer and eating Czechs, yes.
喝假啤酒、吃捷克啤酒，是的。
Like, how was that fake beer?
就像，假啤酒怎么样？
How was that fake beer to drink?
那假啤酒怎么喝？
I don't, I like, I like fake beer.
我不，我喜欢，我喜欢假啤酒。
Yeah.
是的。
I mean, if it was in a bottle, it was water.
我的意思是，如果它装在瓶子里，那就是水。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
It was in a podcast.
这是在一个播客中。
See, I didn't even know that.
你看，我什至都不知道。
Yeah, if it was in a podcast.
是的，如果是在播客中。
Okay.
好的。
And Dave Baker would always ask you, you know, which you preferred, yeah.
戴夫·贝克总是会问你，你知道，你更喜欢哪个，是的。
Anyway, all right.
无论如何，好吧。
Or did you prefer?
或者你更喜欢？
Craig, speaking of which, Hayden Sprinkle asks, what drink did you get at McGee's?
克雷格，说到这里，海登·斯普林克问道，你在麦吉店喝了什么饮料？
Me?
我？
Oh, I was there for like 20 minutes.
哦，我在那里待了大约20分钟。
So I had...
所以我有...
Only seven shots of it.
只拍了七张。
I had seven shots of it.
我拍了七张。
Because I'm 50 years old and that would go well.
因为我已经50岁了，那会很顺利。
No, I had a McGee's L.
不，我有一张 McGee’s L。
They have their own good beer and the two how much of other fans that I was talking to you for a few minutes, I bought them their round of drinks too, despite them not knowing the podcast, but I hope I've gilded them into following our lovely podcast.
他们有自己的好啤酒，还有我和你们聊了几分钟的其他粉丝，我也给他们买了一杯饮料，尽管他们不知道播客，但我希望我已经让他们喜欢上了我们可爱的播客。
And I wrote you this little ditty to send you in New York City.
我给你写了这首小曲，寄给你在纽约市。
We'll be right back.
我们马上回来。
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the Hyper-Fixed Podcast.
大家好，我是 Alex Goldman，Hyper-Fixed 播客的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会收集听众的问题并尝试为他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York.
比如，我已经 30 岁了，我害怕在纽约开车。
Or, why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者，为什么我倒车时无法调节汽车音响的音量？
We also solve non-car related problems.
我们还解决非汽车相关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
如果您遇到问题，我们不仅会修复它，还会首先暴露导致该问题的隐藏系统。
That's the Hyper-Fixed podcast from Radiotopia.
这是来自 Radiotopia 的 Hyper-Fixed 播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts or at hyperfixedpod.com.
无论您在哪里找到播客或在 hyperfixedpod.com 上都可以找到它。
And now, back to the show.
现在，回到节目。
So a couple things also for those of you who have, again, friends, obviously with a lot of people from overseas here, for whom it is very, very early.
对于那些有朋友的人来说，还有几件事要讲，显然这里有很多来自海外的朋友，对他们来说，现在还非常非常早。
We have many people mentioning, I would join this, but it's you who told me that nothing good happens after 2 a.m., says Swarly Memes, but let everyone know and please let your friends know, this will appear as a podcast in our feed.
我们有很多人提到，我会加入这个，但是你告诉我凌晨 2 点之后不会有什么好事发生，Swarly Memes 说，但让每个人都知道，并请让你的朋友知道，这将作为播客出现在我们的动态中。
So in a couple of weeks, if you're, tell your friends- It's like a bonus episode right now.
因此，几周后，如果您愿意，请告诉您的朋友 - 这就像现在的奖励剧集。
Yeah, they'll be able to listen to this, just subscribe, subscribe to that podcast.
是的，他们将能够收听这个，只需订阅，订阅那个播客。
So we have great questions, Hemi, and they're all sort of really big picture ones, which I think is fun.
所以我们有很好的问题，海米，它们都是非常大的问题，我认为这很有趣。
So let's just go with this one.
那么我们就以这个为例吧。
Josh, what episodes filming is the most memorable or emotional for you?
乔什，拍摄的哪一集对你来说是最难忘或最感人的？
The whole series.
整个系列。
That's tough one.
那是很难的一件事。
208 episodes in here to scroll through there.
这里有 208 集，可以在那里滚动浏览。
Or even up on the more recent ones that I've been watching.
或者甚至是我最近看过的一些。
I think I can only contain that to the first two seasons just because they're so fresh in my mind of having just watched them.
我想我只能把它限制在前两季，因为我刚刚看完它们，对它们记忆犹新。
Fair.
公平的。
I mean, what was the question, what was the most, like, emotional or emotional?
我的意思是，问题是什么，最感人的还是情绪化的？
Yeah, the choice, memorable or emotional?
是啊，这个选择，是难忘的还是感性的？
You know, we just watched the showdown with Bob Barker, you know, Neil Barney's dad, into something borrowed and something blue, and we were talking about how it's almost a three-part finale, because remember Robin and Ted walk in and showdown with, like, covered in like a tomato sauce from, and it's a mystery again, like you don't know why.
你知道，我们刚刚观看了与鲍勃·巴克（你知道，尼尔·巴尼的父亲）的对决，变成了借来的东西和蓝色的东西，我们正在谈论这几乎是一个由三部分组成的结局，因为记住罗宾和泰德走进来摊牌，就像，像番茄酱一样，这又是一个谜，就像你不知道为什么一样。
And then in the finale you understand what happened.
然后在结局中你就会明白发生了什么。
And I, there's a series of scenes with me and Kobe that starts in the restaurant where he had stolen the blue French horn for earlier in the pilot.
而我，有一系列我和科比的场景，从餐厅开始，他在试播集早些时候偷了蓝色圆号。
And then there was an actual proposal that we talk about, the couple that you see get engaged in the show, that was him actually proposing his wife.
然后我们谈论了一个实际的求婚，你看到的那对在节目中订婚的夫妇，那是他实际上向他的妻子求婚。
That's an actual real-life marriage proposal, yes.
是的，这就是现实生活中的求婚。
They're still married, three daughters were thrilled to have learned this.
他们仍然结婚了，三个女儿得知这一消息很高兴。
And then the scenes, the breakup scenes where they're telling Barney and popping back to Robin's apartment, I was really proud of me and Kobe.
然后是他们告诉巴尼并回到罗宾公寓的分手场景，我真的为我和科比感到骄傲。
Like, I thought they were really great, well-acted scenes.
就像，我认为它们真的很棒，表演得很好。
I know it's a little weird to say, like, those scenes.
我知道说这些场景有点奇怪。
It's not weird.
这并不奇怪。
They're so good.
他们太好了。
We're so good together.
我们在一起很好。
And we had like two years of history kind of fooling it.
我们有两年的历史在愚弄它。
And I really, I just loved it.
我真的很喜欢它。
And I loved, you know, I loved what a good friend Ted is to Marshall up until he can't take it anymore when Lily leaves.
我喜欢，你知道，我喜欢特德对马歇尔来说是一个好朋友，直到莉莉离开后他再也无法忍受了。
And I love the, I had forgotten how much Lily leaving for San Francisco and breaking Marshall's heart reverberates throughout the entire second season.
我喜欢这个，我忘记了莉莉离开旧金山并伤了马歇尔的心在整个第二季中产生了多大的影响。
Like my memory of it was like she comes back and all is forgiven and it's not that way at all.
在我的记忆中，她回来了，一切都被原谅了，但事实并非如此。
It's not.
它不是。
And I thought that was really great.
我认为这真的很棒。
I mean, some of it I noticed like, oh, I'm really proud of us as actors, but I'm also a writer and a director.
我的意思是，我注意到其中一些，哦，我真的为我们作为演员感到自豪，但我也是一名作家和导演。
So when I watch it now, I'm really intrigued and excited by like talking to Craig about.
所以当我现在看它时，我真的很感兴趣，也很兴奋，就像和克雷格谈论的那样。
Like, where'd you come up with that?
就像，你从哪里想到的？
Like, that was so smart to like plant that seed in this episode and have it pay off three episodes later.
就像，在这一集种下种子并在三集后得到回报，真是太聪明了。
And just how they were playing the long game while also trying to satisfy the network wanting these to be episodes that you could just tune in on any random Monday night and like, but they were trying to tell this serialized story.
他们是如何进行长期游戏的，同时也试图满足电视网的要求，希望这些剧集成为你可以在任何随机的周一晚上收听的剧集，但他们试图讲述这个连载的故事。
So it's a cool thing if you're interested in making something, especially a long-form television show that goes for nine seasons, it's really like a masterclass listening to Craig talk about what was going on in the writer's room, how they cracked the story, where they were headed, and when they didn't even know where they were headed and what they did in those situations.
所以，如果你有兴趣制作一些东西，尤其是一部九季的长篇电视节目，这真的是一件很酷的事情，这真的就像听克雷格谈论编剧房间里发生的事情、他们如何破解故事、他们要去哪里，以及当他们甚至不知道自己要去哪里以及在这些情况下他们做了什么的大师班。
Yeah, Craig, let me bring this one to you.
是的，克雷格，让我把这个带给你。
I mean, they're, I mean, this for everyone, obviously, but let's go, I love these, they're really big questions here.
我的意思是，显然，这对每个人来说都是如此，但是让我们走吧，我喜欢这些，它们确实是个大问题。
Let's have this one.
让我们来一份吧。
What lesson from the series has impacted you the most?
该系列中的哪一课对您影响最大？
Oh, that's another tough one.
哦，这又是一个艰难的事情。
Let's do from the first two seasons.
我们从前两季开始吧。
I know, right, we're in the first two seasons.
我知道，对，我们已经进入了前两季。
So, okay, I'll play off with Josh just said, and thank you, Josh, for those lovely words.
所以，好吧，我会和乔什刚才说的一样，谢谢你，乔什，那些可爱的话语。
And like you guys, you and, it is such a writer's dream to write scenes like what you and Colby acted in the sequence you just described and watch it be elevated beyond anything you could have dreamed for that is just such a gift for everybody that wrote on that show.
和你们一样，你和，这是一个作家的梦想，写出像你和科尔比在你刚才描述的序列中表演的场景，并看着它被提升到超越你所能梦想的任何程度，这对每个在该剧中写作的人来说都是一份礼物。
So you guys believe me, we were in awe of you guys there.
所以你们相信我，我们对你们感到敬畏。
I would say, Josh just sort of said it, we had this awkward experience at the end of season one where the network said, make it less serialized.
我想说，乔什只是这么说的，我们在第一季结束时经历了这种尴尬的经历，网络上说，减少连载。
You've done season one, and you did it like a weird little soap opera, right?
你已经完成了第一季，而且你做得就像一部奇怪的小肥皂剧，对吧？
You had your, you're expecting your audience to remember week to week what happened.
你有你的，你希望你的观众能够记住每周发生的事情。
It's exactly what Josh just said, like in season two, you see these echoes and reverberations of the consequences of this really intense emotional thing that happened between Marshall Millie and the way it influences the whole group.
这正是乔什刚才所说的，就像在第二季中一样，你会看到马歇尔·米莉之间发生的这种真正强烈的情感事件的后果及其影响整个团队的方式的回声和回响。
Now we were borderline yelled at to stop doing the end of season one.
现在我们几乎被喊叫停止做第一季的结尾。
We was strongly suggested perhaps we might not want to do that and we might want to be more like the others that comes on CBS that were these little standalone things and every week everyone had amnesia and the week before it never happened and I'm really, the answer to that question is, I'm really proud the lesson that we learned.
有人强烈建议我们也许不想这样做，我们可能想更像哥伦比亚广播公司的其他节目，这些都是独立的小事情，每周每个人都会失忆，而前一周它从未发生过，我真的，这个问题的答案是，我真的为我们学到的教训感到自豪。
Fuck that.
他妈的。
Now, let's write the show we want to write.
现在，让我们写我们想写的节目。
Let's write the show we want to see.
我们来写我们想看的节目吧。
It's right how we would want to watch a TV show, which at that time was binging TV shows on DVDs because it was pre-streaming because we're a thousand years old, but it turned out to be a really safe bet, a really smart bet because people now consume TV very differently.
这正是我们想要观看电视节目的方式，当时人们正在观看 DVD 上的电视节目，因为它是预流媒体，因为我们已经一千年了，但事实证明这是一个非常安全的赌注，一个非常明智的赌注，因为人们现在对电视的消费方式非常不同。
And that happened during our run and people caught up to it on Netflix when it got on Netflix or sort of like season four or so, and our bet paid off.
这发生在我们的运行过程中，当它在 Netflix 上播出时，人们就在 Netflix 上观看了它，或者有点像第四季左右，我们的赌注得到了回报。
Our bet was we have a smart audience.
我们打赌我们有一群聪明的观众。
They want to watch things that matter week to week.
他们想每周关注重要的事情。
They want to watch the show have its own internal memory and they want to see consequences and reverberations and echoes and setups and callbacks and twists and turns and call forwards where you see something and you go, what?
他们想看节目有自己的内部记忆，他们想看到后果、回响、回声、设置、回调、曲折和向前召唤，你看到一些东西，然后你就去，什么？
What is that?
那是什么？
Like a flash forward and then it's explained to episodes later.
就像快进一样，然后在后面的剧集中进行解释。
We did the thing of right for your smartest audience, right for your smartest, best, most sensitive audience and thank you, how I met your mother fans for approving us right because what a gift.
我们为你们最聪明的观众做了正确的事情，为你们最聪明、最好、最敏感的观众做了正确的事情，谢谢你们，我是如何认识你们妈妈的粉丝的，你们对我们的认可是正确的，因为这是一份多么好的礼物。
Well, also I think you guys were writing about, like I call the, how I met your mother, you are like 27 to 36, right?
嗯，我想你们也在写，就像我所说的，我是如何认识你母亲的，你们大概在 27 岁到 36 岁之间，对吧？
Like the, that's how old the characters were when in the show.
就像，这就是剧中角色的年龄。
But if you look at those years, your 20s and your early 30s, those years are very consequential.
但如果你看看那些年，你的 20 多岁和 30 岁出头，那些年是非常重要的。
And everything you've done stacks up towards the next thing.
你所做的一切都会累积到下一件事中。
So it's like, you can't, I think you use the term etch a sketch.
所以就像，你不能，我认为你使用术语“蚀刻草图”。
Like you can't like shake the etch a sketch and start a little bit.
就像你不能像摇动蚀刻草图并开始一点点一样。
Like it has to be, things have consequences in meaning and you make your next move based on either the success or failure of your last move.
就像必须的那样，事物都会产生意义，你会根据上一步的成功或失败来制定下一步行动。
So I think it's a more emotionally honest show that you had a memory, like the flame of memory going the whole time, at least in which the whole show is a memory.
所以我认为这是一个在情感上更诚实的节目，你有一段记忆，就像记忆的火焰一直在燃烧，至少整个节目都是一段记忆。
It's a show about how at that time of real life, life starts to acquire meaning.
该剧讲述了在现实生活的那个时期，生活如何开始获得意义。
Yes.
是的。
And consequence.
和后果。
The etch a sketch part is over.
蚀刻草图部分就结束了。
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊，是啊。
That's right.
这是正确的。
It's more grooved, you know.
它更加凹凸有致，你知道。
Two things that I, just lines that stick out for me, I was sharing something about how in the middle of the night, like you shouldn't trust your thoughts when you wake up in the middle of the night.
有两件事对我来说很突出，我在半夜分享了一些关于如何在半夜醒来的事情，比如当你半夜醒来时，你不应该相信自己的想法。
And it actually occurred to me like nothing good happens after 2 a.m.
事实上，我觉得凌晨两点之后就没有什么好事发生了。
Is a good phrase not just for, you know, go home, but also like if you wake up after 2 a.m.
这是一个很好的短语，不仅适用于回家，还适用于凌晨 2 点后起床的情况。
Nothing good is really happening in your head.
你脑子里并没有真正发生什么好事。
Like most of the time that's where your anxiety strikes or your worst-case scenario, thinking happens.
就像大多数时候，当你的焦虑或最坏的情况发生时，思考就会发生。
So I reframe nothing good happens after 2 a.m.
所以我重新定义了凌晨两点之后不会发生什么好事。
for myself, which is like, nothing good happens up here.
对我自己来说，这就像，这里没有什么好事发生。
That's brilliant, I'm stealing that because that's when bad shit happens in my mind.
太棒了，我偷了它，因为那是我脑子里发生糟糕事情的时候。
Oh my God, yeah.
天哪，是的。
But what do you then do with that?
但是你用它做什么呢？
How do you put it at least?
至少你怎么说？
Well, I try it right.
嗯，我试试就对了。
It is like by naming it, you shrink it by naming it.
就像通过命名它一样，你通过命名它来缩小它。
I try to bracket everything as saying like, this is an unreliable narrator in my head.
我试着把所有的事情都括起来，比如，在我的脑海里，这是一个不可靠的叙述者。
Ha ha ha ha.
哈哈哈哈。
Like this is not someone to be trusted.
这样的人就不是一个值得信任的人。
Yes.
是的。
that that whatever that is, drawing is our erroneous.
不管是什么，绘画都是我们的错误。
Like they're so bad.
好像他们很糟糕一样。
Yes.
是的。
So I try not to listen.
所以我尽量不去听。
And I've spoken a lot about this, but in the pilot, Ted has the whole thing about, you know, it's not like I imagined my wedding.
关于这一点我已经谈了很多，但在试播集中，特德讲述了整个事情，你知道，这不像我想象的那样我的婚礼。
And then he has this, you know, down to perfect detail.
然后他就做到了，你知道，细节都很完美。
He's imagined the wedding.
他想象着婚礼。
And then at the end he says, bam, no DJ, people will dance.
最后他说，砰，没有 DJ，人们会跳舞。
I'm not gonna worry about it.
我不会为此担心。
And I spoke about this in the podcast that the phrase people will dance.
我在播客中谈到了“人们会跳舞”这句话。
I actually named my corporation, people will dance because to me, it's almost like the opposite of nothing good out.
实际上，我给我的公司起了个名字，人们会跳舞，因为对我来说，这几乎就像没有什么好结果的对立面。
It's a rallying cry for the optimist, right?
这是乐观主义者的战斗口号，对吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Like, life will take care of itself, there will be joy, there will be celebration, people will dance and I don't have to worry about it.
就像，生活会照顾好自己，会有欢乐，会有庆祝，人们会跳舞，而我不必担心。
And people have gotten tattoos around that phrase because of your celebration.
由于你们的庆祝活动，人们在这句话周围纹上了纹身。
You called that phrase out, you're the one that underlined that phrase.
你喊出了这句话，你就是在这句话下划线的人。
After playing music or sorry.
播放音乐后还是抱歉。
And they say, can you write people will dance, I'm going to get a tattoo of it.
他们说，你能写下人们会跳舞吗，我要去纹身。
Which is the epitome of the statement right there dancing we've we've just been asked by J.S.
这是我们刚刚被 J.S. 询问的那句话的缩影。
Crogs when the people will dance merch will be dropping and you know we'll uh you guys come to the website and buy it then maybe we'll do it.
当人们跳舞时，Crogs 的商品将会掉落，你知道我们会呃，你们来到网站上购买它，然后也许我们会这样做。
I mean that would be a cool dance.
我的意思是那将是一段很酷的舞蹈。
They would be a really cool shirt.
它们会是一件非常酷的衬衫。
If I saw someone and I didn't know what that phrase meant I'd be like that's a cool shirt.
如果我看到某人而我不知道这句话的意思，我会觉得那是一件很酷的衬衫。
What's that what does that mean?
那是什么意思？
All right you intuitively know what it means.
好吧，你直观地知道这意味着什么。
Yeah you really know what it means.
是的，你确实知道这意味着什么。
All right we're doing it.
好吧，我们正在做。
Okay, we've got Mexico, we've got Portugal, we've got Siberia, and the matching thing could be people with pants, pants.
好吧，我们有墨西哥，我们有葡萄牙，我们有西伯利亚，匹配的东西可能是穿裤子的人，裤子。
Is that anything?
那有什么吗？
We'll come back to that later.
我们稍后再讨论这个问题。
That's more of a, for the latter many years, it's one of us.
这更像是，在后来的许多年里，它是我们中的一员。
Yeah, you know what Dave did that.
是的，你知道戴夫做了什么。
It's a deep call.
这是一个深沉的呼唤。
By the way, Fatima.seif.mirz asks the important question.
顺便说一下，Fatima.seif.mirz 问了一个重要的问题。
Alec, did you ever make a cameo?
亚历克，你客串过吗？
Did you, is that you, is that you?
你、是你吗、是你吗？
Is anyone would ask for many of that question?
有人会问很多这样的问题吗？
That I see right through that show.
我通过那个节目看到了这一点。
You see right through that.
你看透了这一点。
Okay, I am going to ask the question though, Jessica Wallace, XOXO, I see your question, and thank you.
好吧，我要问这个问题，杰西卡华莱士，XOXO，我看到你的问题，谢谢你。
You can answer the question.
你可以回答这个问题。
No, oh, thanks, you know, I am on the show.
不，哦，谢谢，你知道，我在节目中。
I play Todd in episode something or other in the first season, best prom ever.
我在第一季的某集里扮演托德，这是有史以来最好的舞会。
And you can go check that one out.
你可以去看看那个。
Here's this is a nice question.
这是一个很好的问题。
We, I think I'm young people watch the show, right?
我们，我想我是看节目的年轻人吧？
And sometimes we're taking a little aback at the ages that are pitched as being appropriate to start with.
有时我们会对被认为适合开始的年龄感到有点惊讶。
But Kush777 says, are there any lessons or messages you want young people or teenagers to take from the show?
但 Kush777 说，你希望年轻人或青少年从这部剧中学到什么教训或信息吗？
I'm 16, and it is my favorite show.
我16岁了，这是我最喜欢的节目。
Josh, I mean, I have an answer.
乔什，我的意思是，我有一个答案。
Do you have an answer?
你有答案吗？
I think I know what the answer is.
我想我知道答案是什么。
I could come up with an answer.
我可以想出一个答案。
But what do you think?
但你觉得呢？
What's yours?
你的是什么？
Here's my answer.
这是我的答案。
The world is so intense and dark right now.
现在的世界是如此激烈和黑暗。
I have such sympathy, empathy, heartache for young people right now, looking at the lack of sympathy and empathy in the world right now.
我对现在的年轻人充满同情、同理心和心痛，看到现在世界上缺乏同情心和同理心。
And I just hope that when they look at a show that is about a future version of yourself looking back on all the times that feel chaotic and confusing and impossible, that there's some sense or hidden message there that says you're going to be okay, there's going to be a future version of you that gets through all this chaos and is there at the other side of it to tell your story.
我只是希望，当他们看一部关于未来版本的你回顾所有感觉混乱、令人困惑和不可能的时光的节目时，那里有一些有意义或隐藏的信息告诉你你会没事的，未来版本的你会度过所有这些混乱，并在它的另一边讲述你的故事。
And I hope I like to believe that's why the show does speak to people who are in their teens and twenties and people are finding it in a younger generation.
我希望我愿意相信这就是为什么这个节目确实与十几岁和二十多岁的人交谈，并且人们在年轻一代中找到了它。
I hope that it gives them comfort.
我希望这能给他们带来安慰。
It's a really hard moment to look ahead to the future, but I have to believe in my heart of parts that you're going to be telling the story of all this and you're going to come out the other side.
展望未来，这是一个非常艰难的时刻，但我必须相信我内心的部分，你将讲述这一切的故事，你将走出另一边。
I love that, Craig.
我喜欢这个，克雷格。
Can I add something?
我可以添加一些东西吗？
Please.
请。
Um, I think Einstein said the thing about the only question you have to decide for yourself is if it's a friendly universe or not.
嗯，我想爱因斯坦说过，你必须自己决定的唯一问题是它是否是一个友好的宇宙。
Yeah.
是的。
And how I met your mother, I think one of the reasons it's so beloved, beloved, beloved.
我是如何认识你母亲的，我认为这是它如此受人爱戴、爱戴、爱戴的原因之一。
My wife and I have a disagreement about how to say that.
我和我的妻子对于如何说这句话存在分歧。
What a weird argument.
多么奇怪的争论啊。
Yeah.
是的。
biggest fight.
最大的战斗。
I mean, knock down, drag out.
我的意思是，击倒，拖出。
You know, I think that how I met your mother posits that it's a friendly universe.
你知道，我认为我是如何认识你母亲的，这表明这是一个友好的宇宙。
Yes, it does.
是的，确实如此。
And I think that's so comforting to people.
我认为这对人们来说非常令人安慰。
I think it's also true, because I believe the universe is ultimately friendly.
我认为这也是真的，因为我相信宇宙最终是友好的。
That doesn't mean that darkness doesn't have its day and doesn't have its moment.
这并不意味着黑暗没有它的日子，也没有它的时刻。
And that's in this show too?
而且这个节目里也有这样的事吗？
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
That is also in this show.
这也是在这个节目中。
Yeah.
是的。
But my friend sent me today, I'm gonna get real deep here for just a moment.
但我的朋友今天发给我的，我要在这里深入探讨一会儿。
Forgive me if this isn't your thing.
如果这不是你的事，请原谅我。
He sent me a quote from the Damapada, which is a Buddhist text.
他给我寄了一段佛教经典《达摩波达》中的引述。
And I love this.
我喜欢这个。
It says, in this world, hate never yet dispelled hate.
它说，在这个世界上，仇恨从未消除仇恨。
Only love dispells hate.
只有爱才能驱散仇恨。
This is the law, ancient and inexhaustible.
这就是法则，古老且取之不尽用之不竭。
You two shall pass away knowing this.
你们两个将知道这一点而去世。
How can you quarrel?
你们怎么能吵架呢？
However many holy words you read, however many you speak, what good will they do you if you do not act upon them?
无论你读了多少圣言，无论你讲了多少圣言，如果你不付诸行动，它们对你有什么好处呢？
read as few words as you like and speak fewer, but act upon the law.
尽量少读、少说，但要遵纪守法。
This law that love dispels hate.
此法以爱驱散恨。
And I just, you know, it's such a dark moment and it's such a hard time to not fall into cynicism or feel that like darkness is winning, but it doesn't, it never will.
我只是，你知道，这是一个如此黑暗的时刻，这是一个很难不陷入愤世嫉俗或感觉黑暗正在获胜的时期，但它不会，永远不会。
It ultimately, it just never will.
最终，它永远不会。
And the thing I like about what that says, it's a law.
我喜欢这句话的一点是，它是一条法律。
I love that word.
我喜欢这个词。
It's a law there.
那里有法律。
Yeah, that's not like negotiable.
是的，这不是可以谈判的。
It's a law, and I feel like how I met your mother honors that law.
这是一条法律，我觉得我遇见你母亲的方式尊重了这条法律。
Yeah, I think so.
是的，我想是的。
I think so.
我想是的。
I think that is the law of how much a mother.
我想这就是母亲的法则。
I agree.
我同意。
Mark, underscore our rampage, our rampage.
马克，强调我们的狂暴，我们的狂暴。
What's to know about, what lessons you learned about, I'm sorry, what lessons you learned about writing throughout the show.
要知道什么，你学到了什么教训，对不起，你在整个节目中学到了关于写作的什么教训。
You sort of talked about the sticking to your gun's idea, but how about the actual act of story, structuring out a story you hadn't I mean you could talk a little bit about what TV you had written prior to this but nine years I hope you learned something what did you learn in the writing world and Josh too I mean in the midst of all this you wrote a couple of movies and then have kept have continued to write what lessons do you learn about writing throughout the show.
你谈到了坚持你的想法，但故事的实际行为如何，构建一个你没有的故事我的意思是你可以谈谈你之前写过的电视节目，但九年来我希望你学到了一些你在写作世界中学到的东西，乔什也是我的意思是在这一切中你写了几部电影，然后继续写你在整个节目中学到的写作经验教训。
The times we felt we were in trouble were the times where we we didn't quite have the story figured out.
当我们觉得自己遇到麻烦的时候，我们还没有完全弄清楚这个故事。
It was always about that stage.
总是与那个阶段有关。
It was always about the story.
这总是关于故事。
It was always about what's on the big dryer raceboards, Act 1, Act 2, Act 3, and then how do we translate that to a really robust outline, like 10 pages, single spaced scene by scene outline, what here's every scene, here's why those scenes are there, here's how that scene starts, here's how that scene ends.
它总是关于大型烘干机赛马板上的内容，第一幕、第二幕、第三幕，然后我们如何将其转化为真正强大的轮廓，比如 10 页，一个场景一个场景轮廓的单行距，每个场景是什么，这就是这些场景存在的原因，这是该场景如何开始，这是该场景如何结束。
And in the middle of those scenes later, Future U, this is Future U's problem, We'll write jokes.
稍后在这些场景中间，未来 U，这是未来 U 的问题，我们会写笑话。
And it's really fucking easy to write jokes when you know what the story is, and it's really fucking hard to write jokes when you don't.
当你知道故事是什么时，写笑话真的很容易，而当你不知道故事是什么时，写笑话真的很难。
And when it's just freestanding jokes based on nothing, there are geniuses who can write like that.
当它只是毫无根据的独立笑话时，有天才可以写出这样的文章。
Jack Handy, deep thoughts.
杰克·汉迪，深思熟虑。
Stephen Wright, the comedian, right?
斯蒂芬赖特，喜剧演员，对吗？
There's like, there's geniuses that can out of nowhere have a perfect 12-word joke.
就像，有些天才可以凭空编出一个完美的 12 字笑话。
But boy, it is way easier to write jokes when you're writing about the story and running with the character and the situation, the jokes come.
但是，当你在写故事并与人物和情境结合起来时，写笑话就容易多了，笑话就来了。
It's not that hard.
这并不难。
So that's my biggest lesson.
这就是我最大的教训。
It's about story.
这是关于故事的。
Create that shape, do the work ahead of time, worry about the dialogue and the jokes later.
创建那个形状，提前做好工作，稍后再担心对话和笑话。
I learned a lot from you guys about the pleasure of withholding in some ways, like creating confusion and then the pleasure of of solving it, I also kind of learned, it's kind of a von, a Kurt Vonnegut thing.
我从你们那里学到了很多关于以某些方式隐瞒的乐趣，比如制造混乱，然后解决它的乐趣，我也学到了，这是一种冯·冯内古特的东西。
He says like, create characters that your audience will love and then put them through hell.
他说，创造观众会喜欢的角色，然后让他们经历地狱。
Yes, yes, that's it, that's it.
是的，是的，就是这样，就是这样。
And you have to love those characters and your heart has to be broken putting them through hell too or else you're just a sociopath.
你必须爱这些角色，你必须心碎，让他们也经历地狱，否则你就是一个反社会者。
Like you have to as a writer be like, I love them so much and I'm putting them through hell to learn something about them.
就像作为一名作家必须要做的那样，我非常爱他们，我让他们经历地狱般的事情来了解他们。
And also to ultimately deposit them, hopefully in a better place than when they start.
并且最终将它们存放在比开始时更好的地方。
somewhere better that they could never have gotten to without the hell part, without the Shawshank sewer pipe.
没有地狱部分，没有肖申克下水道，他们永远无法到达更好的地方。
Carter is really, Carter Bay is a really, he's a master of risk confusing the audience.
卡特是真的，卡特贝是真的，他是一个迷惑观众的风险大师。
Carter's really good at that.
卡特在这方面确实很擅长。
He's like, that sounded like a backwards compliment or something, I mean it as a high praise.
他说，这听起来像是一种反向恭维之类的，我的意思是这是一种高度赞扬。
Oh yeah.
哦，是的。
They don't need to know what's happening for a minute.
他们一分钟都不需要知道发生了什么。
You can plant things that are confusing and pay them off later.
你可以种植一些令人困惑的东西，然后再还清它们。
Carter was a real, it was and is a real master of that.
卡特是一位真正的大师，无论是过去还是现在都是一位真正的大师。
So I feel like I learned a lot from him.
所以我觉得我从他身上学到了很多东西。
I had a singing teacher at NYU, Debbie Lapidus, who I just adored and continued to adore, but she, oh, you know, Alec, we did a thing with her.
我在纽约大学有一位歌唱老师黛比·拉皮德斯 (Debbie Lapidus)，我很喜欢她，而且一直很喜欢她，但是她，哦，你知道，亚历克，我们和她做了一件事。
I did.
我做到了。
But she always used to say, play to the smartest people in the room.
但她总是说，要和房间里最聪明的人一起玩。
Yeah.
是的。
And it was like the best thing I heard in grad school.
这就像我在研究生院听到的最好的事情。
Just like, don't go for the widest audience, go for like the audience that is gonna really be tuned into your frequency of what you're saying and then the audience will grow.
就像，不要去争取最广泛的受众，而是去寻找真正能适应你所说内容的频率的受众，然后受众就会增长。
I said a similar thing earlier.
我之前也说过类似的话。
It's like, we wrote for the smart audience.
就像，我们是为聪明的观众而写的。
We didn't think people had to forget week to week what the fuck was happening.
我们不认为人们必须一周又一周地忘记他妈的发生了什么。
Like it's, and it paid off.
就像它一样，它得到了回报。
Like there's some, there's something about this.
就像有一些，有一些关于这个。
What is the staying power of the show?
节目的持久力有多大？
That's one of our biggest questions of this podcast.
这是我们这个播客最大的问题之一。
Why?
为什么？
Why has it stayed?
为什么它留下来了？
Why has the, why has it found all these new people?
为什么，为什么它找到了所有这些新人？
I have another Buddhist text I'd like to read.
我还有一本佛经想读。
Please do.
请这样做。
Yeah, I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
是的，我开玩笑，我开玩笑。
But it really is like, it's a message in a bottle and you're just hoping it will find people and you know, people will dance.
但它确实就像是，这是一个瓶子里的信息，你只是希望它能找到人们，你知道，人们会跳舞。
People will dance.
人们会跳舞。
Just a couple of technical things for the show.
只是该节目的一些技术问题。
Megan Almond asks, how far out do you record podcasts?
梅根·阿尔蒙德问，你录制播客的距离有多远？
Wanna know so we could submit episodes, specific letters and voice notes in time.
想知道这样我们就可以及时提交剧集、具体信件和语音注释。
Quite a ways in advance.
提前了相当多的路。
I would say go ahead and submit anything, anytime.
我想说的是，随时提交任何内容。
And you definitely do not need to connect your voice note or your letter to a specific podcast at all.
而且您绝对不需要将您的语音笔记或信件连接到特定的播客。
Also, before we do a recording, if you're on at Howie major mother, that's our Instagram account, we reach out for questions and we call those general questions.
另外，在我们进行录音之前，如果您在 Howie Major mother（这是我们的 Instagram 帐户）上，我们会提出问题，我们将这些问题称为一般性问题。
General questions, all right.
一般问题，好吧。
You jumped on the gun.
你跳上了枪。
I might not have done it, but I did it.
我可能没有做到，但我做到了。
So please take your time on that.
所以请花点时间。
And Nicole Flank asks, can you do a live show tour?
妮可·弗兰克 (Nicole Flank) 问，你能进行现场巡演吗？
That would be amazing.
那真是太棒了。
I mean, in time, guys, I think we'll, we hope to hit the road.
我的意思是，伙计们，我想我们会及时上路的。
It will be fine.
会没事的。
We've got a long time.
我们还有很长的时间。
We've got a long way to go.
我们还有很长的路要走。
We'll be fine, yeah.
我们会没事的，是的。
We're only in season two.
我们现在才第二季。
Yeah.
是的。
Who knows?
谁知道？
But we love it.
但我们喜欢它。
A lovely question from Eric with a lot of letters after that, but you'll know where to go with this.
埃里克（Eric）提出了一个可爱的问题，之后有很多信件，但你会知道该去哪里。
But Josh, did you ever get a chance to meet Bob Saget?
但是乔什，你有机会见到鲍勃·萨吉特吗？
lots of times.
很多次。
Yeah, I met him day one.
是的，我第一天就认识了他。
I mean, he's presupposing a much greater separation between the voice over and Bob was Bob loved the show.
我的意思是，他假设配音和鲍勃之间有更大的分离，因为鲍勃喜欢这个节目。
Yeah, Bob would come to set just drop by.
是的，鲍勃会顺便来片场。
Hang out with us.
和我们一起出去玩吧。
I met.
我遇见了。
I mean, the first season, we had to do much more voice over like in we would go to the, you know, sound stage.
我的意思是，第一季，我们必须做更多的配音，就像我们去摄影棚一样。
Yeah.
是的。
And that was where Bob always was recording so I would hang out with him for a long time and then as the years went on Craig I remember this they would just bring the microphone to they would just have you do a line on stage you wouldn't even have to go to the booth anymore.
那是鲍勃总是录音的地方，所以我会和他一起玩很长时间，然后随着克雷格的岁月流逝，我记得他们只会把麦克风带到他们那里，让你在舞台上唱一句台词，你甚至不必再去录音室了。
Yeah I was decided that it sounded good enough and it had the kind of the same room tone as what we were matching so why put you in a perfect sounding studio and we could record the ADR line in the actual room.
是的，我认为它听起来足够好，并且具有与我们匹配的相同的房间音调，所以为什么要把您放在一个完美的录音室中，我们可以在实际房间中录制 ADR 线路。
Bob and I grew very close over the years, and we would grab dinner about once a year.
这些年来，鲍勃和我关系非常亲密，我们大约每年都会吃一次晚餐。
And yeah, we had a very, very sweet friendship.
是的，我们有非常非常甜蜜的友谊。
I still miss him every day.
我仍然每天都想念他。
Yeah.
是的。
Same.
相同的。
Craig, yeah, sorry.
克雷格，是的，抱歉。
No, I was just gonna say he was, like, so when Carter and I wrote the pilot of the show, we were so young, we were like 29, 30 years old, and Bob signing on to the show.
不，我只是想说他是，所以当卡特和我写这个节目的试播集时，我们还很年轻，我们大约 29、30 岁，鲍勃签约了这个节目。
Bob believing in the show and signing on to be the narrator gave it this sort of gravitas and authority and blessing from a TV God, if you will, right?
鲍勃相信这个节目并签约担任解说员，这给了它这种庄严、权威和来自电视之神的祝福，如果你愿意的话，对吧？
It was like, we needed this idea of a future dad telling his kids the story, what better dad than Bob?
就像，我们需要一个未来的父亲给他的孩子们讲故事的想法，还有什么比鲍勃更好的父亲呢？
From the full house dad, this guy who's been your TV buddy and your TV dad for all of these years, when we booked him, which was for the pilot, without knowing that there was gonna be a series, it really mattered to the show.
来自全屋爸爸，这个多年来一直是你的电视伙伴和电视爸爸的人，当我们预订他时，这是为了试播集，不知道会有一个系列，这对节目来说真的很重要。
It really gave CBS, which was an older scheming network.
它确实给了哥伦比亚广播公司这个老牌的心机网络。
It gave them the sense of like, oh, these crazy young whippersnappers, Carter and Craig, managed to get us a track.
这给了他们一种感觉，哦，这些疯狂的年轻自吹自擂者，卡特和克雷格，设法为我们找到了一首曲目。
Their script attracted somebody significant in TV who feels like he has the right to be narrating and telling this story.
他们的剧本吸引了电视界的一位重要人物，他觉得自己有权叙述和讲述这个故事。
And I think it lent power to the pilot and made people that watched the pilot with skepticism, perhaps, about these young kids writing this show.
我认为它赋予了试播集力量，让观看试播集的人们对这些写这个节目的小孩子可能持怀疑态度。
They'd never, we'd never written our, a pilot.
他们从来没有，我们从来没有写过我们的飞行员。
We'd never done it on our own show.
我们从未在自己的节目中这样做过。
We'd barely ever written on a sitcom.
我们几乎没有写过情景喜剧。
And I think Bob, Bob really helped it get picked up in my opinion.
我认为鲍勃，鲍勃确实帮助它在我看来得到了认可。
And so in addition to everything else he did for nine years for us and being the best guy, it's really part of the journey of how we actually got it on TV.
因此，除了他九年来为我们所做的一切以及成为最好的人之外，这确实是我们如何在电视上真正看到它的旅程的一部分。
Had this old man, he musted me, fell in love with you.
如果这个老男人，他必须我，爱上了你。
New York City.
纽约市。
And now commercials, end of commercials, back to show.
现在是广告，广告结束，回到演出。
Joseph D.
约瑟夫·D.
McLean asks about music.
麦克莱恩询问有关音乐的问题。
And by the way, you know, we do talk a lot, or you do talk a lot about the music choices on the show.
顺便说一句，你知道，我们确实谈论了很多，或者你确实谈论了很多关于节目中的音乐选择。
It's a very different, obviously, use of music than really any other TV shows, certainly of its time.
显然，它对音乐的运用与任何其他电视节目（当然是当时的电视节目）截然不同。
And just ask the music choices to be playing during the scenes, make them iconic.
只需要求在场景中播放的音乐选择，使它们成为标志性的。
What is your favorite music and scene moment together in the show and maybe we'll hold it to the first two seasons whatever first.
你在剧中最喜欢的音乐和场景是什么，也许我们会先把它保留到前两季。
Yeah, it's too hard.
是啊，太难了。
Whatever's fresh in your mind.
不管你脑子里有什么新鲜的。
Even for two seasons, it's hard.
即使是两个赛季，也很难。
But I think hold it to two seasons.
但我认为坚持两个赛季。
Josh, what do you think?
乔什，你觉得怎么样？
I think Block Party is incredible at the end of season one.
我认为第一季结尾时的《街区派对》非常棒。
I got my friend, Jay May, Sea Green, Sea Blue.
我有我的朋友，杰·梅，海绿，海蓝。
I introduced you and Carter, and you guys use that as one of the final of season two.
我介绍了你和卡特，你们将其作为第二季的决赛之一。
I mean, I love the balanced Sebastian.
我的意思是，我喜欢平衡的塞巴斯蒂安。
The use of, is it, we roll the school, or is it?
使用，是吗，我们滚动学校，还是？
We roll the school.
我们滚动学校。
Yeah, we roll the school.
是的，我们开办学校。
The balanced Sebastian song in return of the show.
平衡的塞巴斯蒂安歌曲作为节目的回报。
Tiger.
老虎。
Yeah.
是的。
Which is incredible.
这是令人难以置信的。
I'm trying to, was here comes a regular in?
我正在尝试，这里是常客吗？
It was, not in the first two seasons.
是的，前两季不是这样。
Oh, okay.
哦好的。
When was that?
那是什么时候？
Here comes a regular.
常客来了。
I forget what season it was.
我忘记那是什么季节了。
I remember you guys were very excited about that.
我记得你们对此非常兴奋。
We were very excited.
我们非常兴奋。
They had a great song by the replacements.
他们的替补队员唱了一首很棒的歌。
I literally played that song on guitar two day with my son Elliot.
我和儿子埃利奥特两天用吉他弹了这首歌。
Literally like two hours ago.
就像两个小时前一样。
It isn't Barney Stinson named after one of the members of the band.
它不是以乐队成员之一的名字命名的。
The bass player Tommy Stinson of the replacement said that is the namesake of Barney Stinson.
替代者的贝斯手汤米·斯廷森（Tommy Stinson）说，他就是巴尼·斯廷森（Barney Stinson）的同名者。
So we also use the replacement song Skyway, not in the first two seasons.
所以我们也使用了替代歌曲Skyway，而不是前两季。
These were all later.
这些都是后来的事了。
But yeah, in the first two seasons, I'm just going to name one that I had forgotten about, and that is illustrative of no other CBS show would have done this song between 8 and 10 in 2006 or whatever it was.
但是，是的，在前两季中，我只想说出一个我已经忘记的歌曲，这说明没有其他 CBS 节目会在 2006 年 8 点到 10 点之间或其他任何时间播放这首歌。
Iggy pops, I want to be your dog, which is an unabashed S&M punk rock song, but it's the episode with Ted and Robin and all her dogs looking at her ex-boyfriend.
《Iggy pops，我想成为你的狗》，这是一首毫不掩饰的 S&M 朋克摇滚歌曲，但在这一集里，泰德和罗宾以及她所有的狗都看着她的前男友。
Yeah, stop.
是的，停下来。
The episode's stuff where it's that idea of one of your exes giving you and how the, once Once you know something was given to your significant other by an ex, it sort of, it becomes that person.
这一集的内容是，你的一位前任给了你一个想法，一旦你知道前任给了你的另一半一些东西，它就变成了那个人。
All of Robin's dogs were part of her relationships with other guys.
罗宾的所有狗都是她与其他男人关系的一部分。
They all become human to Ted in Josh's favorite moment in the history of shooting how much a mother he had to get licked on the face by one of the actors.
在乔什拍摄史上最喜欢的时刻，他们都成为了特德的人，他拍摄了一位母亲必须被其中一位演员舔脸的镜头。
And there's a sequence in that of Robin walking the dogs that go from dogs to humans set to Iggy Pops, I want to be your dog, which is like a seminal punk rock, and it's absolutely bonkers song.
在《罗宾遛狗》中，有一段从狗到人类的片段，配以《Iggy Pops，我想成为你的狗》，这就像一首开创性的朋克摇滚，这绝对是一首疯狂的歌曲。
and I had forgotten for, I just, I'm, shame to say, I forgot we put that on the show.
我忘记了，我只是，我很遗憾地说，我忘记了我们把它放在节目中。
Carter and I love that song.
卡特和我喜欢这首歌。
And when we got up to that, I was like, fuck yeah, man.
当我们做到这一点时，我想，操，是的，伙计。
King of Queens and Two and a Half Men were not putting any pop songs on that.
《皇后之王》和《好汉两个半》并没有在上面放任何流行歌曲。
No, it's funny though, because it is like, it's a song about S&M, but it's also like, in the context of the show, it literalizes the song.
不，这很有趣，因为它就像是一首关于 S&M 的歌曲，但它也像是在节目的背景下，它字面化了这首歌。
Like, it makes it like less dirty, because it's like all about dogs?
就像，它让它变得不那么脏，因为它就像狗一样？
Yes, it makes it, it tames the song at first, CBS, eight, 30 and a half.
是的，它做到了，它一开始就驯服了这首歌，CBS，八点，三十点半。
So there's great needle drops, which are like you and Andy Gao and you guys making the decision as overseers and creatives.
所以有很棒的落针，就像你和高安迪以及你们作为监督者和创意人员做出的决定一样。
But then there's songs within the show.
但节目中还有歌曲。
Like, you give love a bad name in the limo episode.
就像，你在豪华轿车那一集中给爱情带来了坏名声。
It's like an incredible.
这就像一个不可思议的事情。
Right, right.
对，对。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
Hell man, there's a word for that.
天哪，有一个词可以形容这一点。
Alec Filmerd, what's the word for one of the show is this song is used in a scene, as opposed to on the soundtrack.
亚历克·菲尔默德（Alec Filmerd），其中一个节目的词是这首歌是在场景中使用的，而不是在配乐中使用的。
Fuck, we'll get there.
他妈的，我们会到达那里。
There's a clever term for it, but yeah, and then the original the original songs like I mean Let's go to the mall Carter and I wrote that song So I get saying that makes me sound narcissistic to say that's one of my favorite songs But like what Kobe did with that song and the music video that emerged from that is one of my favorite things in the car series You know it's another another one is bang bang bang itty bang is a really good song classic.
有一个聪明的术语，但是，是的，然后原始歌曲就像我的意思是让我们去商场卡特和我写了那首歌所以我说这让我听起来很自恋，说这是我最喜欢的歌曲之一但是就像科比对那首歌所做的那样以及从中出现的音乐视频是汽车系列中我最喜欢的东西之一你知道这是另一首是bang bang bang itty bang是一首非常好的经典歌曲。
That's a great song Just where it goes the journey of it.
这是一首很棒的歌曲，就在它的旅程中。
That's another single entendre That's just about banging.
这是另一个单义词，就是关于敲打。
Dying jettings, right?
垂死喷射，对吗？
It's about, yeah, no, it's a percussion.
这是关于，是的，不，这是打击乐。
So wait, what did you think it was about?
等等，你认为这是关于什么的？
I thought it was percussion.
我还以为是打击乐
Yeah.
是的。
Emily reminds us that the word is diegetic, by the way.
顺便说一句，艾米丽提醒我们这个词是叙事性的。
Diegetic.
饮食。
Emily said that.
艾米丽这么说。
That's some producing.
那是一些制作。
Emily, that's our social media producer.
艾米丽，这是我们的社交媒体制作人。
Well, all the time, buddy.
好吧，一直以来，伙计。
Emily Blumberg, that is fantastic.
艾米莉·布隆伯格，太棒了。
Fantastic.
极好的。
I am one of our beloved.
我是我们心爱的人之一。
Couple of things to point out.
有几点需要指出。
Yeah, so I'll put this out there.
是的，所以我会把它放在那里。
C-J-Y-K-T-H-I-A-N-77 says, has anyone made a Spotify or Apple music playlist with all the songs used in the show?
C-J-Y-K-T-H-I-A-N-77 说，有人用节目中使用的所有歌曲制作了 Spotify 或 Apple 音乐播放列表吗？
I believe so.
我相信是这样。
I think so.
我想是的。
And then also smaller ones for the season or smaller, like, here's all the original songs written for the show.
然后还有适合本季或更小的歌曲，例如，这里是为该节目编写的所有原创歌曲。
Yeah, please.
是的，请。
When we post this episode, let's link a couple of the playlists.
当我们发布这一集时，让我们链接几个播放列表。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
So there's a lot.
所以有很多。
People have curated it in ways and like I go look at that when we're gonna do our like fundraiser concert.
人们以各种方式策划了它，就像我在我们要举办类似筹款音乐会时会去看一下。
I'm like, I forgot we used that.
我想，我忘了我们用过它。
So the fans are always smarter than us.
所以球迷总是比我们聪明。
This will save me a phone call.
这样我就不用再打电话了。
Emily, if you're listening, can you find this playlist for us?
艾米丽，如果你在听的话，能为我们找到这个播放列表吗？
Now, WorkWork underscore Eliza123 says something that I think is tantalizing.
现在，WorkWork underscore Eliza123 说了一些我认为很诱人的事情。
And I guess I'd like her to tell us more.
我想我希望她能告诉我们更多。
She says, Josh, I was named after your grandmother Rose.
她说，乔什，我是以你祖母罗斯的名字命名的。
Is this, hold on.
是这个吗，等等。
Who said this?
这句话是谁说的？
We need more information.
我们需要更多信息。
WorkWork underscore Eliza123.
WorkWork 强调 Eliza123。
You were named after my grandmother Rose.
你是以我祖母罗斯的名字命名的。
Well, here's another curveball.
好吧，这是另一个曲线球。
Both my grandmothers were named Rose.
我的祖母都叫罗斯。
Whoa.
哇哦。
Yeah.
是的。
So which one was that?
那是哪一个？
That feels like the end of a Sherlock Holmes message.
这感觉就像夏洛克·福尔摩斯的信息的结尾。
Or like the riddle of like the doctor operating on their child.
或者就像医生给孩子做手术的谜语一样。
Because Lincoln had a secretary named Rose.
因为林肯有一位秘书，名叫罗斯。
That's amazing.
太棒了。
But her name's Eliza.
但她的名字叫伊丽莎。
Unclear.
不清楚。
So hopefully she'll write to us in some other way and let us know.
所以希望她能以其他方式写信给我们并让我们知道。
Okay.
好的。
Let us know.
让我们知道。
I mean, I'm intrigued.
我的意思是，我很感兴趣。
We need more information.
我们需要更多信息。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊。
Craig, I'll ask this question, then I'll expand it out a little bit.
克雷格，我会问这个问题，然后我会稍微扩展一下。
Halley Forbes says any fun ideas for an episode if you could write one today.
哈雷·福布斯 (Halley Forbes) 表示，如果你今天能写一个剧集，有任何有趣的想法。
I'll say that as we're recording these episodes, every now and then, you know, Josh is pitching you jokes that you are sad that you didn't include in the series, the first time around.
我想说的是，当我们录制这些剧集时，乔什会时不时地给你讲一些笑话，你会为自己第一次没有包含在该系列中而感到难过。
So do you come up, do you still walk down the street and go, oh, that would be good for an episode of how I met your mother?
那么你还会上来吗，你还会走在街上然后走，哦，这对于我如何遇见你母亲的一集会有好处吗？
It's more like thing, like little things happen that I know I would have put on the show or we would have put on the show or like Carter and I both have this.
这更像是一件事情，就像发生了一些小事情，我知道我会在节目中上演，或者我们会在节目中上演，或者像卡特和我都有这样的事情。
We've talked about this.
我们已经讨论过这个了。
The other day, a friend of mine had their phone playing the one song they like from some artist, and won't say what it was because it seems like I'm shitting on the artist.
有一天，我的一个朋友的手机正在播放某位艺术家的一首他们喜欢的歌曲，但他没有透露那首歌是什么，因为看起来我在嘲笑这位艺术家。
And they were the kitchen doing something and their phone was like on the counter and their phone then fell down in the space between the counter on the refrigerator and just stayed on that artist for like three hours.
他们在厨房里做某事，他们的手机就像在柜台上一样，然后他们的手机掉到冰箱柜台之间的空间里，并在那位艺术家身上呆了大约三个小时。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
Cause it was, you couldn't get to the phone.
因为你无法接电话。
They, she needed to get the super to come get the phone.
他们，她需要让管理员来拿电话。
And just the idea that you like this one song, like let's, the Proclaimer is 500 miles and almost feels like that.
只要你喜欢这首歌，就像让我们，《宣言者是 500 英里》，几乎就是这样的感觉。
And so then for like three hours, she's hearing this one, every other song by this artist on like Spotify, like that artist.
就这样，在大约三个小时的时间里，她在 Spotify 上听到了这首歌曲，以及这位艺术家的所有其他歌曲，就像那位艺术家一样。
And I thought that was so funny.
我觉得这很有趣。
I thought that would be in the background of an entire How I Met Your Mother episode.
我以为这会成为整个《老爸老妈浪漫史》的背景。
It would just be like, I just could picture the music budget would be.
就像，我可以想象音乐预算是多少。
The music budget would be.
音乐预算是。
You know what you'd have to do?
你知道你必须做什么吗？
You'd have to make a special deal with that artist.
你必须与那位艺术家达成一项特殊协议。
You'd have to be like, hey, listen, we're featuring you.
你必须说，嘿，听着，我们正在以你为主角。
But you couldn't say.
但你不能说。
You couldn't show me how you want to solve.
你无法告诉我你想如何解决。
But you'd have to be like, hey, there's a lot of, it turns out there's a lot of great songs, but you'd have to play it all a little bit.
但你必须说，嘿，有很多，事实证明有很多很棒的歌曲，但你必须全部播放一点。
But I thought it was such a funny idea that you're just stuck listening to this one thing.
但我认为这是一个非常有趣的想法，以至于你只能听这件事。
And just like little things like that Carder pointed out the story one time that at the end of how much a mother we're talking about, how do we turn this off in our brains?
就像卡德有一次指出的这样的小事情一样，在我们谈论了多少母亲的故事的最后，我们如何在我们的大脑中关闭它？
Apparently some Cheers writer, if there's any Cheers fans out there, the youngins might not know it is a great show, a huge influence on Carder and I.
显然是《干杯》的编剧，如果有《干杯》的粉丝，年轻人可能不知道这是一场精彩的演出，对卡德和我影响巨大。
And there was a character called Norm and Cheers, it was a show about a bar.
还有一个角色叫Norm and Cheers，这是一个关于酒吧的节目。
And every time Norm walked into the bar, he said that he had a great line.
每次诺姆走进酒吧，他都说他的队伍很长。
He had an entrance line that was a joke, and there was like 200 of them.
他的入场队伍简直就是个笑话，大约有 200 人。
And you can go watch a cut down on YouTube, go search Norm entry lines on Cheers and you will see 200 hilarious jokes.
你可以在 YouTube 上观看剪辑，在 Cheers 上搜索 Norm 条目，你会看到 200 个搞笑笑话。
And some writer for Cheers told the story where he didn't cry at the final table read, he didn't cry at the final shoot, he didn't cry at the rap party.
《Cheers》的一些作家讲述了这样的故事：他在决赛桌朗读时没有哭泣，在最后的拍摄中没有哭泣，在说唱派对上他没有哭泣。
No, when Cheers ended after like 10 or 11 seasons, the moment this one writer cried, was like two months after the show ended in the shower when he thought of a Norm entry line and realized I can never write that for Norm again.
不，当《干杯》在大约 10 或 11 季后结束时，这位作家哭泣的那一刻，就像是节目在淋浴中结束后两个月，当时他想到了 Norm 的入口台词，并意识到我再也不能为 Norm 写这个了。
And that was the moment it all came out.
就在那时，一切都真相大白了。
That's how it feels, that's how it feels.
就是这样的感觉，就是这样的感觉。
Well Craig, I imagine though for a decade, you and Carter just had your antenna just going, do do do do do do do like always on the hunt.
好吧，克雷格，我想，十年来，你和卡特的天线一直在转动，就像一直在寻找一样。
Yes.
是的。
For material and for ideas.
为了材料和想法。
Yeah.
是的。
I actually, I brought this up I think a couple episodes ago that there's that Twitter thing of like if Seinfeld happened today, like modern Seinfeld or Seinfeld today.
事实上，我在几集前就提到了这一点，如果《宋飞正传》今天发生的话，就会有 Twitter 上的类似内容，就像现代的《宋飞正传》或今天的《宋飞正传》一样。
Yeah.
是的。
And we talked about if how I met your mother was on today And, you know, the U.S., whatever, the mint or whatever, they just discontinued the penny.
我们讨论了《我如何遇见你母亲》是否会在今天播出 而且，你知道，美国，无论如何，造币厂或其他什么，他们刚刚停止发行便士。
Yes.
是的。
And Ted would have probably gathered again together to do like a little, a little funeral for the penny.
特德可能会再次聚集在一起，为便士举办一场小小的葬礼。
It would taste full of memorial service.
它会充满追悼会的味道。
Yeah, to tell what they were saying goodbye to.
是的，告诉他们他们正在告别什么。
People would understand it.
人们会理解的。
Yeah, I guess I got a little downtown out too.
是的，我想我也去市中心了一点。
Well, when you said that, a couple of episodes ago, I thought that was the perfect example.
好吧，当你在几集前这么说时，我认为这是一个完美的例子。
That was just like, I actually felt sad when you said it was like, God damn it, we can't do that.
就像，当你说“该死的，我们不能那样做”时，我实际上感到很难过。
But then a little bit happy because we can talk about it on the podcast and sort of make it a thing.
但后来有点高兴，因为我们可以在播客上谈论它，并让它成为一件事。
Like we can honor that a great idea, that it's such a great observation.
就像我们可以尊重这个伟大的想法，这是一个伟大的观察。
I thought, Josh, that said so much to me about like, you as an actor and like when an actor really inhabits a character, like I saw that news story and didn't think of Ted.
我想，乔什，这对我说了很多关于你作为一名演员的信息，以及当一个演员真正融入一个角色时，就像我看到那个新闻报道但没有想到泰德一样。
But you had to inhabit Ted and some that's still there in your brain and you saw the news story and you thought, what would Ted think of it?
但你必须记住特德和你大脑中仍然存在的一些东西，当你看到新闻报道时，你会想，特德会怎么想？
I just wanted the crowd to know I'm not into pennies.
我只是想让大家知道我不喜欢钱。
I just remembered.
我刚刚想起来了。
That is a dead thing, but just like that's still in you, that's still in you and it delays me.
那是一个死的东西，但就像它仍然在你体内一样，它仍然在你体内，它耽误了我。
Just so you guys know, people are giving you guys love in all sorts of ways.
只是想让你们知道，人们正在以各种方式给予你们爱。
Josh, a lot of congratulations to you, by the way.
乔什，顺便说一句，非常祝贺你。
That was the, you get breaking news on the how we made your podcast.
就是这样，您会收到有关我们如何制作播客的突发新闻。
You get breaking fucking news.
你会得到他妈的重大新闻。
That was the baby announcement for Josh Ratter.
这是乔什·拉特 (Josh Ratter) 的婴儿公告。
Congratulations, Josh Ratter and your nana.
恭喜乔什·拉特和你的奶奶。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Phenomenal.
非凡的。
Craig, lots of mentions of your recent, your literary baby, your book, that a lot of people have read and are saying lovely things about here.
克雷格，很多人都提到了你最近的作品、你的文学宝贝、你的书，很多人都读过这些书，并在这里谈论了很多可爱的事情。
Thank you, premium fans.
谢谢你们，优质粉丝。
You've been amazing for that.
你在这方面表现得很出色。
And thank you, Josh and Kobe, for being on the audio book of that, please, it's called That's Not How It Happened.
谢谢乔什和科比出现在有声读物中，这本书的名字叫《事情不是这样发生的》。
Go check it out.
去看看吧。
I'm really proud of it.
我真的很自豪。
It's such a good book.
这是一本很好的书。
The audio book is just one of prize today.
有声读物只是今天的奖品之一。
The audio book is Kirk's book reviews, like one of the big literary trade publications.
有声书是柯克的书评，就像大型文学贸易出版物之一。
it does reviews, they named it an exceptional audio book.
它有评论，他们称其为一本出色的有声读物。
They give it a prize today, I'm a earphone prize.
他们今天给它颁奖，我是耳机奖。
And that is, I'm proud of it for me, but I'm really proud of it for the cast of Josh and Kobe and Kevin and Marley.
也就是说，我为自己感到自豪，但我也为乔什、科比、凯文和马利的演员阵容感到自豪。
And they absolutely nailed creating a whole world of these characters that is in some ways beyond what I wrote and it's just, it's such a gift as a writer.
他们绝对成功地创造了一个由这些角色组成的整个世界，在某种程度上超出了我所写的范围，这对作家来说是一种天赋。
So thank you, thank you, Josh, thank you to everybody.
所以谢谢你，谢谢你，乔什，谢谢大家。
You were great, you were great.
你很棒，你很棒。
And while we don't wanna encourage quite so much copy pasting in the comments here, we'll just go ahead and give it to Joseph F9, who has asked many times.
虽然我们不想鼓励在评论中进行太多的复制粘贴，但我们还是将其交给 Joseph F9，他已经问过很多次了。
Josh, if you're doing any more live events soon, your tour is over as of a couple of months ago, right?
乔什，如果你很快就要举办更多现场活动，那么你的巡演几个月前就结束了，对吧？
Nothing coming up.
什么都没有发生。
No, although I have a new album that is pretty much done.
不，虽然我有一张新专辑已经完成了。
So I'm gonna have to figure out how to let people know about it and maybe, I don't know, I've never had a small child here before.
所以我必须想办法让人们知道这件事，也许，我不知道，我以前从未在这里养过小孩。
So I don't know, apparently they do better when you're around more.
所以我不知道，显然当你在身边的时候他们会做得更好。
I've heard, is that a rumor?
我听说了，是谣言吗？
Is that a rumor?
这是谣言吗？
Yeah, that might be debunked, but I'm trying to be here.
是的，这可能会被揭穿，但我正在努力留在这里。
So if there are any music or anything, I'll let you guys know, keep a watch on the socials and I'll let you know what comes up.
因此，如果有任何音乐或任何事情，我会让你们知道，请密切关注社交活动，我会让你们知道发生了什么。
I will say we are going to do a little hymnium music scene.
我想说我们要做一些赞美诗音乐场景。
Sorry, we're going to do a little hymn on June 20th at Bowery Ballroom at 8 p.m.
抱歉，我们将于 6 月 20 日晚上 8 点在 Bowery 宴会厅演奏一首小赞美诗。
Saturday, June 20th.
6 月 20 日，星期六。
We were doing the How I Met Your Mother themed fundraiser concert, the Music of How I Met Your Mother.
我们正在举办《老爸老妈的浪漫史》主题筹款音乐会，《老爸老妈的浪漫史》音乐。
It's our fourth time doing this.
这是我们第四次这样做了。
We have some amazing hymnium folk, including Joshy, come in to make music.
我们有一些很棒的赞美诗人，包括乔希，进来创作音乐。
And so get your tickets to that.
所以，拿到你的门票吧。
It sells out really fast.
它卖得很快。
The tickets just went out.
票刚出去。
So please come join us for that.
因此，请加入我们。
It's fantastic.
太棒了。
It's for an amazing cause that helps kids like my son that I won't get into exactly everything about that.
这是为了帮助像我儿子这样的孩子的一个惊人的事业，我不会详细介绍这一切。
But like, it's amazing.
但就像，这太神奇了。
It's a wonderful night.
这是一个美好的夜晚。
And how many years have it been this year?
而今年已经多少年了？
This is our fourth year spread across six years because of the pandemic.
这是我们因疫情而跨越六年的第四个年头。
It was supposed to be annual, but there was a pandemic.
本来应该是一年一度的，但是却发生了大流行。
But we were back into it, and it's great.
但我们又回到了原来的状态，这很棒。
The tickets are on sale now.
门票现已发售。
Go grab it, come hang out with us.
快去抢吧，和我们一起出去玩吧。
We have a lot of immediate responses, new album in all caps by many people.
我们立即得到了很多回应，很多人都用大写的新专辑。
So Josh, can you talk about one that might come out or what the data is?
乔希，你能谈谈可能出现的一项结果或者数据是什么吗？
You know, I'm kind of hatching a plan.
你知道，我正在制定一个计划。
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah, I don't know yet.
是的，我还不知道。
I should figure it out.
我应该弄清楚。
I'll get on it tomorrow and figure it out.
明天我会着手解决这个问题。
All right.
好的。
It's mostly done.
大部分已经完成了。
Brock's FL1CKS just asks, wait, is this live?
Brock 的 FL1CKS 只是问，等等，这是现场直播吗？
And so, Brock's, yeah.
所以，布洛克的，是的。
It is clear.
很明显。
Now when you listen to it on the podcast, for you it is a bonus episode.
现在，当您在播客上收听它时，对您来说这是一个额外的剧集。
It's live.
这是直播。
unless you're listening to it not live, not on January 21st.
除非你不是在现场听，不是在 1 月 21 日。
All right, let's wind this down with Josh.
好吧，让我们和乔希一起结束这一切。
I wanna find this question, because I like it.
我想找到这个问题，因为我喜欢它。
He wants to know some great advice for achieving inner peace.
他想知道一些关于实现内心平静的好建议。
Des Miller says, Josh, what's your biggest advice for achieving inner peace?
德斯·米勒说，乔什，对于实现内心平静，你最大的建议是什么？
We got some heavy questions tonight.
今晚我们有一些棘手的问题。
I know, this is- I like these questions.
我知道，这是——我喜欢这些问题。
I like it.
我喜欢它。
Me too, I like it.
我也是，我喜欢。
I mean that as a compliment.
我的意思是作为一种恭维。
This is so nice.
这真是太好了。
Yeah.
是的。
Well, I think it's important not to do life alone.
嗯，我认为重要的是不要独自生活。
So it's really good to get, much like how I met your mother, you know, they all come from various dysfunctional childhoods and they find people that they can go through life with.
所以能得到这样的人真的很好，就像我遇见你母亲一样，你知道，他们都来自不同的不正常童年，他们找到了可以一起度过一生的人。
So it's like a chosen family, you know, and I don't know, that doesn't have to be a spouse, it can be a community, it can be something you're passionate about where you just find people to stand shoulder to shoulder with and believe in something together and laugh together and eat food together and be there for each other.
所以这就像一个选定的家庭，你知道，我不知道，它不一定是配偶，它可以是一个社区，它可以是你热衷的东西，你只是找到人们并肩站在一起，一起相信某件事，一起笑，一起吃饭，互相支持。
So I think not doing life alone.
所以我觉得不要一个人生活。
And I also think, you know, really being unafraid to know your mind and see and look at your mind.
我还认为，你知道，真的不害怕了解你的想法，看到并审视你的想法。
You know, there's a part of us that is always at peace and has equilibrium and it's the cut the witness and then there's this other these other parts that are going to be you know 2 a.m.
你知道，我们的一部分总是处于平静和平衡状态，这是见证人的切入点，然后还有其他这些其他部分，你知道凌晨 2 点。
3 a.m.
凌晨 3 点
2 a.m.
凌晨 2 点
do it there things but the witness can watch those parts and just when you observe it it takes some of the kind of kerosene out of the fire I guess and I think meditation is a really smart thing to do I've never heard someone who started meditating and felt like it was a negative in their life, so to get quiet, and also just to really lead with kindness.
在那里做一些事情，但目击者可以观察这些部分，当你观察它时，我想它会从火中取出一些煤油，我认为冥想是一件非常聪明的事情，我从来没有听说过有人开始冥想并觉得这是他们生活中的消极因素，所以要保持安静，而且只是要真正以善意来引导。
We can't really change other people, we can only change ourselves.
我们无法真正改变别人，我们只能改变自己。
I try not to get out too much into twisting the knobs of reality.
我尽量不去太多地扭曲现实。
Of course, I want people to behave differently than they are behaving, but I really try to know that my own behavior is the only anything I can control.
当然，我希望人们的行为与他们的行为有所不同，但我真的试图知道我自己的行为是我唯一可以控制的。
So just try to, you know, walk a little lighter and be of service and be kind and not let, not believe everything you think, you know, a lot of what our minds bits up is.
所以，你知道，尽量放轻一点，服务他人，友善一点，不要让、不要相信你所想的一切，你知道，我们脑子里的很多想法都是如此。
I don't know.
我不知道。
It's, it's at least to be interrogated in question because not everything I think is hot off the press, you know, a lot of it is just anxiety, old thought patterns, know, it's hard to think something new and do something new.
至少要受到质疑，因为并不是我认为的所有事情都是新闻报道中热门的，你知道，很多只是焦虑，旧的思维模式，知道，很难思考新事物并做新事物。
Um, but, uh, I don't know, that was a lot of things.
嗯，但是，呃，我不知道，那是很多事情。
I hope there was something in there.
我希望里面有东西。
That's fantastic.
太棒了。
Those were good things.
这些都是好事。
Fantastic.
极好的。
Um, okay.
嗯，好吧。
Thank you, everyone.
谢谢大家。
By the way, in the, in the chat here, uh, Emily Bloomberg has posted a link to the fundraiser where you can get tickets for that now.
顺便说一句，在此处的聊天中，呃，艾米丽·布隆伯格发布了一个筹款活动的链接，您现在可以在那里获取门票。
Oh, cool.
哦，酷。
Yeah, put that on our website.
是的，把它放在我们的网站上。
Thank you, Emily.
谢谢你，艾米丽。
Well, everything.
好吧，一切。
Yes, the wonderful Emily works with us on the podcast, always, always of service and fantastic.
是的，出色的艾米丽在播客上与我们一起工作，始终如一地提供服务，非常棒。
Thank you, Emily.
谢谢你，艾米丽。
And yes, So go grab tickets, it's gonna go fast.
是的，所以去买票吧，速度会很快。
It's been out for a week or two.
已经出来一两周了。
It's already gone.
它已经消失了。
Yeah.
是的。
All the socials have links to that.
所有的社交活动都有与之相关的链接。
And again, please, please, please right now.
再说一次，拜托，拜托，拜托，现在。
Go ahead and subscribe to this podcast everywhere that you get your podcasts.
继续在您收到播客的任何地方订阅此播客。
And tag a friend or three.
并标记一三个朋友。
Like try to, if you love the show, if you love how I made a mother, if you love this podcast, we wanna include you as part of the army who's gonna help spread the word and bring more people to us.
就像尝试一下，如果你喜欢这个节目，如果你喜欢我如何成为一个母亲，如果你喜欢这个播客，我们希望你成为军队的一员，帮助传播信息并吸引更多的人加入我们。
because we think we're doing something really fun, really meaningful here.
因为我们认为我们正在做一些非常有趣、非常有意义的事情。
We were having a great time and we'd like more people to join us.
我们度过了一段愉快的时光，我们希望更多的人加入我们。
And it's just the more the merrier, so come along.
越多越好，所以一起来吧。
I am guilty.
我有罪。
Please acquit me.
请释放我无罪。
All sins are forgiven.
所有的罪孽都被宽恕了。
New York City.
纽约市。
How we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas and is presented and distributed by the Office Ladies Network and Odyssey.
《我们如何造就你的母亲》由乔什·拉德纳 (Josh Radner) 和克雷格·托马斯 (Craig Thomas) 主持并监制，并由 Office Ladies Network 和 Odyssey 出品和发行。
This episode is also executive produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
本集还由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛担任执行制作。
The show is produced and edited by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Matata.
该节目由我 Alec Lev 制作和编辑，我们的联合制作人是 Doug Matata。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Point of Blue Studios 的 Alex Reeves。
Our digital content producer, aka Gen Z Master, is Emily Blumberg.
我们的数字内容制作人，又名 Z 世代大师，是 Emily Blumberg。
Artwork by John Morrow.
约翰·莫罗的艺术作品。
Please follow, rate and review the show on Apple Podcasts your podcast player of choice.
请在您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论 Apple 播客上的节目。
It really does help the show.
对节目确实有帮助。
Our theme song is New York City by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的 Josh Radner 创作的《New York City》，其他音乐由 Craig Thomas 和 Andrew Majuski 创作。
Special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢洛拉·肯尼迪和埃利奥特·康纳斯。
Visit HowWeMajorMother.com to learn more and click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
请访问 HowWeMajorMother.com 了解更多信息，然后单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's newsletters on Substack, and check out his music and everything else at JoshRadner.com.
在 Substack 上订阅 Josh Radner 的时事通讯，并在 JoshRadner.com 上查看他的音乐和其他所有内容。
Order Craig Thomas's debut novel, That's Not How It Happened, wherever books are sold, and check out his other published writings at CraigThomasRider.com.
无论哪里有卖书，都可以订购克雷格·托马斯的处女作《That's Not How It Happened》，并在 CraigThomasRider.com 上查看他出版的其他作品。
And you can subscribe to my own Dead Fathers Society, also on Substack.
你也可以在 Substack 上订阅我自己的 Dead Fathers Society。
To learn more about how you make a difference, This shows ongoing campaign to raise money for congenital pediatric heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
要了解有关如何做出改变的更多信息，这显示了正在进行的为先天性儿科心脏病研究筹集资金的活动，请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”选项卡。
will, in fact, dance.
事实上，会跳舞。